good afternoon everyone thank you for
being here today
today i wanted to provide some updates
for nevadans as it relates to
protections in place
for tenants and landlords when the cdc
eviction moratorium lifts at the end of
this month
i'm grateful today to be joined by
i'm grateful today to be joined by uh
shannon chambers president of the board
of directors from home means nevada
and kevin schiller assistant county
manager for clark county
who you will hear from briefly we first
implemented an eviction moratorium early
on in the pandemic
to help residents stay home for nevada
keeping nevadans safe in their homes
helped slow the spread
of covet 19. as the pandemic has changed
and evolved
so has our approach to the moratorium
and we've been able to build out rental
assistance programs
with state and county partners mediation
programs with the court system
and most recently by partnering with the
nevada legislature
to create a so-called glide path for
evictions
more on that in a moment i want to thank
all of the dedicated and steadfast
partners in this work
who have spent countless hours working
to create
fair and just systems to ensure that
tenants
don't lose their housing through no
fault of their own and to make sure
landlords
get the money that they are owed we're
in a much better
place because of this work earlier this
year i
signed assembly bill 486 legislation
brought forward in collaboration with
assemblyman steve yeager
and senator julia raddy and alongside
center majority leader nicole canazzaro
and assembly speaker
jason fryerson i think the assemblyman
was able to join us here on this zoom
i wanted to talk briefly about what this
legislation does
and why it's so important then shannon
will talk about how to apply for this
assistance
and kevin will provide an update on the
work in clark county on this initiative
broadly speaking this legislation helps
ensure that qualified tenants who are
awaiting rental assistance applications
to be processed are protected from being
evicted
for non-payment of rent we have plenty
of rental assistance money available
through funds from the federal
government and there are dedicated
people at all levels of government
working to process those payments as
quickly as possible
directly to landlords on behalf of the
tenants
ab486 was enacted and creates a glide
path
for the end of the eviction moratorium
the law ensures that both landlords and
tenants will receive the benefit
of 360 million dollars in federally
funded
rental assistance to keep tenants in
their homes pay landlords
and prevent avoidable evictions this
sets nevada up for more long-term
success
it will help prevent unnecessary
evictions when the cdc moratorium lifts
on july 31st i want to be clear
if you are a renter you must apply for
this assistance
shannon and kevin will shortly go over
how to do so
filling out and submitting an
application is the best thing you can do
right now
if you fear you may be evicted for
non-payment of rent
under ab-486 if the tenant raises the
defense of a pending rental assistance
application the court will stay the case
until mediation or determination on the
tenant's application
if rental assistance is available a
landlord can accept it
and the tenant can remain housed and
avoid a preventable eviction
if the tenant desires to move out there
can be an agreement on the move-out date
with payment
the parties are free to work out any
agreement that makes sense for them
declogging the court calendars and
avoiding evictions which may be
may prevent attendant from being able to
re-rent a unit
are all positives again i want to thank
all of those who have been involved in
quickly
creating and standing up these systems
that minimize the harm done to nevadans
who have been out of work and adversely
affected by the covet 19 pandemic
we will continue to monitor this process
and make adjustments as necessary
in particular i want to send a special
shout out to thanks to barbara buckley
and to our treasurer zach konan for the
work they have done
to make these programs possible thank
you barbara and thank you zach
at this time i'd like to turn it over to
shannon to discuss
more in depth how nevadans can access
these services
shannon so good afternoon governor
syslak thank you very much and thank you
all today on this call
my name is shannon chambers i'm the
president of home means nevada
last october we were appointed as the
administrator of the rental eviction
mediation program
and took that role and tasked very
seriously and implemented the program
very quickly with the support and
assistance of governor sislek and his
administration
legislative leadership and great
assistance from chief justice hardesty
and the nevada supreme court so to the
governor's point
what i really need to emphasize today is
as a tenant and as a landlord you need
to take action
to access the available rental
assistance funds
home means nevada has a complete
website called therenterconnect.org
that has information on how to apply for
rental assistance
for each of the counties in the state of
nevada we will also
be activating the landlord rental
assistance form
effective august 1st 2021
to allow landlords to apply for rental
assistance
under assembly bill 486 the key point to
remember
is that rental assistance still runs
through the tenant
so while ab486 does provide
some additional options for landlords
the process
still must start and end with the tenant
and i cannot emphasize that enough and i
know mr schiller
will emphasize that as well so tenants
do
need to act and they do need to take
action and fill
out those rental assistance forms
if they are served with a court case
they need to
actively elect to participate in
mediation
and to participate in that process
the benefits of the mediation process is
that it slows down
the eviction process and it allows
the counties and the housing authorities
to process those pending rental
assistance applications or in the
alternative to provide that information
through a mediator to the court so that
the tenant can raise that defense of
potential rental assistance
so under assembly bill 486 and under the
program that home means nevada has built
with the various stakeholders we are
trying to ensure
that no rental assistance application
goes unprocessed
and that no funds are left on the table
but again the tenant and the landlord
must
be active in this process they must
participate
and that comes to the mediation process
as well
if you are a tenant and you elect
mediation
you need to show up to the mediation you
need to respond to the mediator
home means nevada has 86 mediators
currently
under our approved program that on a
whole
are processing in some cases anywhere
between 20 to thirty cases
a week so the more active and more
participatory the tenant and the
landlord are
the more ability we have to governor
siselek's point
to de-clog the court systems and to
resolve these
cases by providing rental assistance
or in some cases coming to other
agreements through
the landlord and tenant maybe it's a
modification of rent
maybe it's simply vacating the property
but again
the tenant and the landlord need to be
active in this process and need to
participate
all the information on how to do this
has been put up on the renter connect
through home means nevada
there is a specific tenant box and a
specific landlord box
which has all the forms has links to all
the counties for rental assistance
and as i stated earlier effective august
1
2021 we will have the landlord rental
assistance form
on our website and just to kind of
outline that process
the landlord will fill out that form
through home means nevada
depending upon the eligibility criteria
and the landlord's answers
we will then send that to the counties
or housing authorities
for review in assembly bill 486
the timeline for that process is up to
60 days
home means nevada has been engaging with
the counties mainly clark county on how
that process will work
and so we have the ability right now
to start that process but again just
knowing that we were going to provide
some information to everybody today
that form will go live august 1st 2021
and home means nevada does know that
landlords are
looking very forward to that form and
very forward to that program and we're
happy to say
that we are ready to move that process
forward
and ready to start accepting those forms
and have landlords fill out those forms
we've also put up frequently asked
questions about the program
on the renterconnect.org and have
information on there on how to submit
additional questions to
home means nevada about that
the key piece to all of this again is
the rental assistance piece and that
runs through the counties
or the housing authorities and again we
have all the information on our website
and for clark county i know kevin
schiller is
on this call today and i'm going to turn
it over to him
to speak specifically how that process
will work
in clark county and again i'm also
available for any questions at the end
so
thank you all very much
uh good afternoon i first want to thank
governor sissellac county nevada legal
aid of southern nevada
and all of our partners for this
opportunity
um to reemphasize a couple pieces since
roughly
june of 2020 um we
have essentially put out about 165
million dollars serving about 90 000
households between utility assistance
and rental assistance
the key message today as shannon was
just referencing
is really focusing on application
on the tenant basis to make sure that
whether it's through ab486
through the eviction process or through
the traditional chap
application that that application does
get filed
we have funds available to do so
we are averaging right now amongst our
almost 400 employees managing this
about 800 to 1000 applications for a
week
i want to put out a couple key pieces of
information to everybody so they're
aware the first
is if you're experiencing this as
shannon just
indicated it's important that you apply
so i want to make sure everybody has the
web portal information which is
chap.clarkcountynv.gov
and all you have to do is click on the
visit portal and i also want to make
sure for landlords that are on this
that they have this number 702-455-4071
which is our landlord portal which
allows for vendor payment to be
expedited once an application is
approved
two other phone numbers one is for legal
aid center of southern nevada which is
386-1079 that's
area code 702 i want to make sure
everybody has that number and again our
helpline is 702-455-4071
two pieces of information we also have
hope link
nevada partners and help with southern
nevada nonprofits here that are helping
support
clients and people applying if they're
having difficulty downloading two of the
key issues that we have seen in terms of
the application processing timelines are
downloaded documents either being in the
wrong location
or the documents themselves or the
incorrect documents so i think it's very
important that i emphasize
that that needs to be a priority i also
want to emphasize that
if you're coming through the eviction
process and they have applied
that essentially becomes a prioritized
application and
ends up in the mediation program as
shannon just indicated
we processed almost 1600 of those to
date since we established the eviction
process
which we spoke about at the governor's
last press conference on this topic
the other piece that i want to make sure
i again emphasize is
please make sure if you are served with
that or if you are experiencing arrears
that you apply a chap
chap.clarkcountynb.gov
it's essential and then for the
landlords we want to make sure and we
recognize it takes a process and time to
expedite payments
that you actually can get into the
portal so if you have trouble i want you
to call 455
four zero seven one um in the current
structure as we're currently sitting
again it's about eight hundred to a
thousand applications per
week and we have about eight thousand
that are currently sitting in the queue
awaiting processing i wanna emphasize
the fact that once that application is
in
and if you reach out related to
mediation that essentially starts the
process so that we have time to
get you processed and get your landlord
paid and with that i'll turn it over
for questions
thank you all again for joining us and i
just want to reiterate
uh uh the number for legal aid the phone
number for legal aid is 702
380
that's 702-386-1070
so thank you thank you everyone and at
this time we'll be able to take some
questions
shannon and kevin if you want to flip
your cameras back on because i think
we'll have some questions for you all as
well
sorry this is megan delaney in the
governor's office if there's any press
on the line that has
questions if you could please use the
raise hand feature and we'll call on you
that way
all right we'll start with terry russell
for the first question terry can you
unmute yourself and ask your question
um i'm checking to see with kevin or
whomever
if i don't live in las vegas or clark
county
do people that live in northern nevada
go to this home means nevada
and maneuver their way through that
system to
fill out forms is that how that's going
to work
thanks terry shannon can you help answer
terry's question please
so good afternoon miss russell that is
correct if you go to renter connect
it has information for all the counties
not just clark county
so we'd have washoe county it has
information about northern nevada rural
housing authority
so if you go to the renter connect.org
it will have
all that information county by county
and have those application forms
for those counties thank you shannon and
thank you terry for the question
we'll go to tabitha michael lyle and
then sasha i see you
in there so tabitha michael and then
sasha
hi uh governor siselek i know that
you've said that you didn't want to
extend the eviction moratorium anymore
but now that covet cases are rapidly
rising and especially with the delta
variant
do you still think a longer moratorium
is inappropriate
no i think that the moratorium expires
this weekend i encourage
everyone to get a vaccine as quickly as
possible
and we can put an end to this virus in
this pandemic but there was not another
state extension of of the eviction
moratorium coming
thanks tabitha we'll go to michael sasha
and then sam
good afternoon this uh question is
actually for kevin
i'm sorry if i missed this but is there
an update on
as far as the backlog if there's still a
backlog for a rental
application and if so could you kind of
go over those numbers
um so i referenced it in my presentation
there's about 8 000 individuals in the
queue
and at one point we were over 15 000 and
we're processing anywhere from 800 to
1000 a week amongst the 400 staff that
are processing applications
[Music]
thanks kevin thanks for the question
michael we'll go to sasha from channel 8
next uh sam and then someone with
jefferson t i don't know if jefferson is
first or last name but
sasha then sam please hello um i don't
know who specifically would be able to
answer this question but in regards to
uh rising rent here in las vegas las
vegas i've spoken to a lot of people who
are having trouble paying as their rent
rises is there anything specifically
in this legislation that would help
people in those types of situations to
kind of make up that extra money that
they can't
can't meet now as their rent goes up
thank you sasha shannon are you able to
to talk about whether there's anything
in the legislation for that thank you
so thank you for the question i'll do my
best to address it but
would certainly ask mr schiller to jump
in the rental assistance funds
are specifically intended to replace
rent that hasn't been paid there is
nothing specific
in those funds that allows flexibility
for affordable housing issues
and that is just the dynamics of those
funds
they are intended to replace rent that
has not been paid
and and as a follow-up to that this is
kevin schiller i would just echo
we are in the process and we have
already allocated using alternative
funds but we're utilizing rescue funds
to support
those on fixed income with raising with
rising rental rates we are working on
processes to
support that because the cost of
rehousing is extensively higher
so just to give you that we are working
on that through our american rescue act
funds
and we have done that already isolated
because we are seeing rising rents with
individuals with fixed incomes
thank you kevin thank you shannon we'll
go to sam
for the next question jefferson t and
then tabitha
i can't tell if your hand's still raised
or if you have another question but
sam and then jefferson thanks for taking
my question
kevin you said that clark had
distributed 165 million
in assistance i'm wondering out of how
much allocated
and for someone else do we have figures
about allocation and distribution on a
statewide level
thanks sam we'll go to kevin first for
clark and then uh shannon might have
statewide numbers for you or we'll
follow up
kevin do you i think this is kevin um i
don't have the absolute total so i can
give you the follow-up on that but i
would estimate we probably have about
another 100 million in availability
through the
partnership with the state of nevada in
coordination with the cities
and then i think your second question
was what was it proportionately and i
think we could follow up on that also to
the state
thanks kevin shannon did you have
anything to add or do you want us to
follow up with sam
megan i would recommend following up
with sam okay sam shoot me an email and
we'll try to get you some
stuff as soon as we can we'll go to
jefferson t for the next question and
then back to tabitha
jefferson it shows that you're unmuted
but if you're speaking we can't hear you
jefferson tyler here can you hear me
hello what organization are you with
uh channel 2 news at arena perfect go
ahead with your questions
hey i just have some close clarification
i had i wanted to ask the 166 million
that's from ab43
correct and uh the 300 million
uh that's for that's for ab46
correct shannon do you have those
numbers handy
megan i would recommend following up on
that question
ab486 and i believe jefferson referenced
ab483
there was not specific state
appropriations to that so i would
recommend
following up on that so is the 140
uh the um
165 million is that out of the 300
million we're talking right now or is
that
the 300 million in addition to that 360
in
addition to that i think you're
referencing the 162 million that kevin
spoke about is that the number exciting
okay
yes so um just to
quantify it for you the 162 million
is based on an allocation from the
initial and
from the consolidated appropriations act
and the initial
um cares funding that came out at the
onset of code
so those are those two cost centers just
so you're aware
okay great thank you for clarifying that
um and you said that
the landlords can apply and that the
tenants can apply but it goes through
the tenant um so in that case does the
money go
to the tenant is what you're saying or
that the landlord has to get the tenant
to apply for
for everything thank you shannon i saw
you come on screen and unmute
can you help us with this one yes
absolutely so
so jefferson so how it works is the
rental assistance process
is still driven by the tenant assembly
bill 486
created a new program that if the tenant
failed to apply for rental assistance
or refuse to respond to requests to
apply for rental assistance
then the landlord could apply and at
that point if the landlord
is determined to be eligible after a
review
then the landlord would receive that
money
thanks for that clarification shannon
we'll take um the next question from
tabitha
if there's anyone else who has a
question uh now would be the time to
raise your hand
or we will pull to a close after tabitha
hi
i have actually two questions but i'll
start with the first one
um why is there such a significant
backlog of pending rental assistance
applications
do we feel like this program has
adequate staff and technology resources
to efficiently respond to the crisis and
the need that we're seeing right now
kevin did you want to speak go ahead
i'll speak to that
um so um first of all across the country
it's a
it's a national issue in terms of the
sure volume but what i would say
is we've added almost
350 staff to support this program
most jurisdictions across the country or
several have turned back
actually the consolidated appropriations
act dollars based on the inability to
get those out the door that has not been
the case in nevada
and nor in clark county um like i said
we're at processing about 800 to a
thousand and that includes several it
updates
which we're all tied to treasury
guidance you have to meet requirements
for audit
to support payment so um it's really a
question of obeying the rules related to
audit
and then processing so that it's
allowable so
i would say in terms of proportionality
we're doing a pretty good job in terms
of getting those dollars out
it doesn't look that way when you see
people that are in the rears and you
have a cue but
as i said previously that processing
it couldn't be expedited any higher than
it currently is
and then the eviction process that we
established with the supreme court
um the state of nevada and the chambers
has really been
a key in expediting in terms of
prioritizing so that people don't become
homeless or locked out of their homes
[Music]
tabitha did you have one more before we
go to terry
yeah i did have one more question and my
last question
um is kind of about uh kovid and like
how concerned are you that the word and
i'm not sure you're the best person to
address justice would be but
um how concerned are you that the
worsening coveted situation will prevent
the nearly 200 000 nevadans who are on
unemployment from securing a job by the
time benefits programs expire in a month
because i think there are some people
that are worried once those benefits
programs expire
um we're going to see more evictions and
more issues that way
and i appreciate the questions but i
think the real question is what can you
do
and what can i do to encourage more
people to get a vaccine
because that's going to prevent them
from having to go further with
unemployment to be able to go back to
work
and the focus we have right now is on
getting a vaccine
and anybody with the media here i
appreciate you making that front and
center
we encourage everyone who has not been
vaccinated
to go out and get a vaccine it's going
to help us it's going to help them it's
going to help
their families it's going to give our
students a chance to have a senior year
in high school or junior year in high
school they gave up a whole year last
year so
the real thing we're trying to do is
encourage everybody if you haven't been
vaccinated please
take the time find out where the
location is nearest you and go get a
vaccine
thanks gov thanks tabatha terry do you
want to take it home with the last
question today
so i just want to make sure i have this
correct
i want to send people to
renterconnect.org
including landlords and this allows
at the tenant driven however but i mean
can landlords pop into this and do this
and
has anybody do you run into where
landlords say
i don't want to i just want my tenant
out i just want them out of the
house apartment and i want to re-rent
the thing i don't want to participate in
any of this stuff
is that an option for a landlord so ms
russell again this is miss chamber
so on therenterconnect.org yes there is
information for landlords and tenants on
there
there will be the new form effective
august first 2021
for the landlords to submit information
to home means nevada
for potential landlord rental assistance
that's all on therenterconnect.org
to your point about landlords saying i
don't want anything to do with this
that has happened in the past one of the
issues that assembly bill 486
is specifically addressing is that if
there is a rental assistance application
that is pending
the landlord cannot simply throw up
their hands and say i don't want
anything to do with this
that application needs to go through the
process
and a determination on that application
that is then reported
through the mediation process to the
court so that
is no longer an option
if there is a rental assistance
application pending
thank you everyone for joining us this
afternoon we appreciate your questions
or great
thought up questions and again i'm going
to ask you and i'm going to implore
everyone please
do what you can to help us encourage
everyone to get out and get a vaccine
wear a mask when appropriate and we can
put an end to this pandemic once and for
all so thank you